recently i shot a video in which i was
just sort of scratching the surface
talking about my experience
teaching philosophy and religious
studies in a maximum security prison for
about about six years as my full-time
job
back in the 2000s
and
one of the comments on on the video um
was particularly striking i hadn't been
following the news quite so much about
what was going on in indiana i knew
things weren't going well
but i hadn't followed the uh the news
about prison education there and what it
is
in a nutshell is um
it's being phased out
it's it's come to an end and there won't
be any more college uh or university
classes taught in indiana state prisons
and i'll talk a little bit about why
that is in the history of it
um in a couple minutes
so i wanted to you know first talk about
my my own reaction to this
and i you know
i have
mixed feelings about it
on the one hand i can empathize
with
some people who see that as a is a good
thing or even as just a sort of
provisionally good thing
given that that the nation is still in
an economic crisis that the economy is
still extremely tight
state
expenditures and state resources are
down
i can understand the motivation
behind it i can even understand the
reasoning that the legislators
if they were operating in good faith and
i think some of them were operating on
good faith and guaranteed some of them
weren't it was just a campaign issue for
for some
i can understand their reasoning
all that said i think that this is in
general
a bad thing
i think that that prison education in
indiana
having the colleges and the universities
actively involved in prison teaching in
inmates gaining
bas ultimately associate's degrees and
bachelor's degrees in prison
state funded i think that was actually a
very good thing and for a number of
different reasons that all kind of
overlap with each other
and i want to preface from the very
beginning
less people think oh you know typical
academic liberal type
i'm not a liberal
i find myself
not able to call myself a conservative
in the same
way that the republican party or
particularly its tea party branch
calls you know conservatism but i'm
definitely
closer to them
particularly on issues having to do with
crime and policing and punishment than i
am to the the left you know the
democratic party
and uh liberals um
so i don't i'm not the typical college
professor i'm kind of a law and order
type of guy
i believe in old-fashioned
you know
punishment is a merited thing and should
be
should be meted out to those who
actually have done things wrong
but at the same time
there's a lot of different ways to
punish there's a lot of different
things involved in corrections beyond
just punishing
and i can i can understand and see all
those sorts of things
so i'm not against what took place in
indiana because i've got some sort of
you know preconceived liberal bias or
anything like that
rather
as somebody who would call themselves
not really so much a conservative but a
traditionalist that means somebody who
believes in
what it is that i'm actually teaching
about somebody who believes that
aristotle and augustine and aquinas
actually got a lot of things about human
nature and society
right and that um you know
really there is a point to
to moral development and there there are
objective standards for that sort of
thing as somebody who who has that point
of view
i think what happened in the indiana was
very short-sighted
and
opportunistic
and in some respects kind of stupid
so it you know it saddens me too because
i having taught in that program and
having
been involved with so many men
who were in my classes
many of whom i got to to know quite well
and some of whom i became friends with
but none of them are affected by this by
the way because they they've all got
their their degrees
but having gone through that
i feel for those who have had something
taken away from them something that was
particularly good in indiana
was working well in indiana
and got
sidelined
so let me talk about
three main
big picture things one will be the
history of what took place
as best as i understand it
the other will be
why i think prison education at least
the kind of prison education that was
going on in indiana was a particularly
good thing good in a lot of different
respects
and then i'll look at some of the
arguments that people have against
prison education that people made to me
during the years
about prison education those who frowned
on it who thought that it was unfair who
thought that it shouldn't be provided to
these guys
and i'll talk about what i think is
right in those objections and what i
think is wrong with those objections
so let's let's talk about the history
first
i started working for ball state in 2002
and when i did
they already had this prison education
program well underway the prison that i
taught at indiana state prison as far as
i understand things
ball state was already there for
a good 15 to 20 years before i got there
so there was a long standing
program there was a commitment
it had become part of the culture not
only part of the culture of the prison
but part of the culture of the entire
department of education or department of
corrections
and and that prison in particular an
indiana state prison was kind of unique
in that respect in that because it was
such a long-term prison and a lot of the
guys there had had long sentences
there weren't a lot of people always
moving in moving out
so there was some kind of constancy
there enough for some really important
communities to to grow
that supported education
the first
real
worries about what was going on
started happening in the late 2000s
and by 2007
my boss
i was working for the department of
philosophy and religious studies at ball
state through extended education so my
boss my chair said
hey you better get on the job market
because there's some stuff going on and
nobody's quite sure about what's going
to happen with this prison education
thing
and so
i
got on the job market and i ended up
having some some interviews
and it's a good thing
i was able to go to fayetteville state
university i had a few different offers
and that's the one that i took it's a
good thing that i did that because i
would have lost my job
and the reason i would have lost my job
is the the department of of corrections
decided
that they wanted to change their whole
approach to prison education and when we
say prison education we mean a lot more
than just college or university
education to start with a lot of these
guys come into prison without a high
school diploma so they have to earn a
ged first and a lot of them have to take
classes in order to
to get themselves up to speed to make up
for the high school that they missed or
that they've been gone from for a long
time
and then they take the ged and then they
they can do other things
there's other things that would qualify
at least in my book as education but
aren't considered to be education
necessarily because they they're tied in
with rehabilitation programs like anger
management or drug rehabilitation but
some education is taking place in those
but what else was taken with taking
place with education is about vocational
training
so a lot of prisons will teach people
how to do
heating and cooling you know
or
culinary arts is another another big one
gardening landscaping
people can learn learn trades to a
certain extent in in prison
and there's there's classes that you can
you can take in this this sort of stuff
so that's good there's also other
training that takes place that's not
done by by educators per se um you know
for instance
the fire the fire people at indiana
state prison all of them were were
volunteers
all of them were prisoners and if there
was a fire they had to like get out you
know get to wherever they were going
they had to be trained so that they
could actually put out the fires and
things like that
um then we had education itself you know
in the sense of college education sort
of like the capstone right
what what brings everything together
gives people a sense of understanding
and perspective
and
what the doc decided to do was to move
away from these four years bachelor's
degrees
which tended to be
in things like you know general studies
but with a lot of liberal arts and
social sciences components
they moved away from that and they
wanted to see
information technology
and
business
associates degrees
and the reasoning behind this was well
that's going to make these people more
employable
not not really a very good
set of reasoning and we'll get to that a
little bit later but that you know
that's what they they did and so
a lot of the people who were teaching
the classes
like i was that were part of a core
curriculum that was humanities-based so
you know for me intro to philosophy
religion in american culture
world religions those were staple
classes that i taught all the time and
then i taught a lot of other classes
like you know critical thinking logic
ethics
um social political philosophy i taught
you know some of the religious studies
sequence i taught the historical
philosophy sequence
and uh all of that went
so all of that disappeared so 2008
that stuff gets gets phased out for the
most part a few people stayed on
um you know i kept my
my contacts some of them within the the
system so i knew like who actually
stayed on with a job who got rehired
after they they sent too many people
home and then didn't have enough people
to do things that they needed to do
so then um
fast forward about another
four years
and we get to last summer
last summer was the last graduation
ceremony
for
bachelor's degrees nobody else is going
to earn a bachelor degree in
indiana
because indiana
the legislature decided to do away with
prisoners ability to receive
financial aid
and
that killed it because
all of those prisoners
almost all those prisoners 99.9
all of them were able to go to four
years of college and they only got four
years eight semesters and if you screwed
it up
you know you would actually have to pay
for your last semester or two semesters
and just to put that in perspective most
of the prison jobs are earning about 25
to 35 cents an hour
so imagine paying for an entire semester
when your
pay rate is
25 cents an hour you you know that that
really put a
a bur in people's boots so to speak to
make sure they kept on track
um
well the state made it impossible for
prisoners to receive that kind of
financial aid
so effectively that that ends the prison
education in indiana
it's sad because it had gone on for a
very long time
many of the other states surrounding
indiana had done away with prison
education a long time ago
there are relatively few states that
actually do any real
you know post-secondary prison education
which which has the greatest effect on
these guys
and indiana was the leader for a while
and now they're completely finished with
it
so
that's something
pretty sad i think
why is it sad well if we want to think
about what kind of goods were actually
at stake
um
i'm going to start out with the most
sort of public policy oriented make your
case to people who otherwise
quite frankly wouldn't care
wouldn't have any sort of sense of
solidarity or sympathy or empathy for
for the the prison students
and that has to do with um
rehabilitation and recidivism or
actually what i like to call the four
r's
recidivism which is the rate of people
reoffending after they get out re-entry
which is not just people getting plopped
out you know the way you see it in the
movies you know they give you some bus
fare and uh you know whatever clothes
you're wearing and say see you later
jack
you know re-entry is something a bit
more complex than that
rehabilitation
and then what i like to call reformation
recidivism is a major issue in the
united states in in our prison systems
we don't have a prison system we have a
prison systems a whole set of networks
that are different from state to state
county to county and then you mix in the
federal stuff and that changes
as well
some of them are much worse some of them
are are better than others
recidivism is a major problem in in
nearly all of them
and recidivism is this oftentimes they
talk about as a revolving door people
get out of prison
and then they end up committing some
sort of crime that gets them back in
prison again
now
it costs a lot of money to keep somebody
in prison
and
if you want to keep them out of prison
there's a number of things you can do
but they generally have to do with these
guys not committing crimes again
and so
you know you can try to affect the
society that they're moving into
um you can try to equalize opportunities
for them because a lot of these guys are
you know quite frankly at a severe
disadvantage when they get out because
they're they're ex-cons
but the best thing to do
is to try to
change the prisoner themselves
and
you want to create more opportunities
for them and give them the skills that
they need in order to
to make those opportunities work for
them and work is the key thing here
being able to have a job that can
provide you an income
that can you know
be the argument to why you shouldn't go
out and commit another crime
um
having something at stake
there's something to that that that's
important i don't want to downplay that
i think it's very important that these
guys be equipped to go out and actually
participate in the workforce just as
much as i do for my other students
but there's something beyond that that
education can and in many cases does
provide
and
it's harder to wrap your head around
this and it's harder to come up with
numbers for this it's harder to
to make the case for this to people who
are kind of a
unsympathetic or already you know
hostile audience
but
what education in particular liberal
education i don't mean politically
liberal i mean in the classic sense of
the humanistic tradition teaching people
history philosophy grammar
composition
um you know
psychology these sorts of things
teaching people how to think giving them
the kind of skills that enable them to
draw analogies to
assess arguments to
look at information sources and to find
better information sources
that kind of stuff
it's usable in the workplace as a matter
of fact if you look at what most
employers want if you look at these big
lists uh the things that always top the
list are things that that philosophy
prepares you for anyway critical
thinking ethics
problem solving you know these sorts of
issues research skills right
and a liberal education if it's done
well ought to afford you that so it
makes you more employable and it makes
you able better able to function in the
workplace
but it also allows you to reflect on
yourself
and here's where we get to the
difference between two different r's
in my view and i can do a different
video about this where i go into more
detail
a lot of people talk in terms of
rehabilitation
and rehabilitation is thinking of the
prisoner
uh you know generally along medical
lines
you want to cure what's what's wrong
with them
and rehabilitation
focuses on doing something to them maybe
teaching them some some skills some
coping techniques
modifying their their structure motives
and behavior
i think that there's there's nothing
wrong with rehabilitation
but i think that there's a much deeper
and more important dimension of
reformation
that ought to be going on and i've seen
that actually taking place
not you know
in one single class but over a
curriculum
and i've seen that taking place not
because the curriculum itself did that
to the students but because the students
grasped what was in the curriculum and
used it
to
sort of reconstruct what was going on
with them bit by bit by bit sort of like
somebody taking a ship
in which parts of the ship are rotten
and have to be replaced and you don't
try to replace the entire ship at once
there's a famous ship of theseus
right you replace this section here and
now you actually can turn your attention
over here and fix this part and fix this
part and gradually you've got a ship
that's actually sea worthy that can see
you through
the storms and and make it to your
destination
that's what reformation is
it's it's not just something that that
a system or
somebody up on high
imposes on somebody else it's something
that's empowering to that that person
who is being reformed where they're able
to act on themselves where they are able
to seize you know the things that are
that are given to them and choose to
actually apply them
and that's what a liberal arts education
affords
it's not as if a business curriculum
couldn't do that
but it's pretty rare
it's not as if studying
hvac couldn't do that
but you would have to have extraordinary
teachers for that to take place
um and i i you know i've never seen it
myself and i have seen plenty of
examples of people who changed
and it's always very particular it's
always something fairly unpredictable
because it depends on the human will
and the capacity for the human will to
to work on itself
and in order to enable that you have to
have a conception of the human will
that
helps people understand what they're
about i mean
it's hard to do
real reformation without some sort of
robust moral theory driving it and and
you can get that outside of philosophy
you can get it through theology you can
get it even to a certain extent in
history or literature
but again you're not going to get it in
the business curriculum and you're not
going to get it
most likely in many other curricula
so
you know if you want to cut recidivism
i mean the statistics tell us that those
students who actually go on to get an
associate's degree or get let alone get
a ba
drastically lower rates of recidivism
why is that
i would say
that it's because in the past
what was actually working
was teaching these guys
a liberal arts oriented curriculum
it wasn't teaching them business or
teaching them you know job vocational
skills it was teaching them how to think
and rethink and reform who it was that
they were and change their their own
structure and motivations and and become
autonomous and become
uh in tune with with real values rather
than just you know whatever substitutes
were getting getting placed on to them
by by you know
their own choices by the the crap
society that they were they were engaged
with by
the media that would stream in
by the environment that they were they
were stuck in
education offered something that that
allowed recidivism to decline because it
allowed reformation to take place
um
there's something else that i want to
talk about too and this this ties in
with um this notion of it being kind of
unpredictable
who's going to change and who's not
you have to recognize that if you have
an educational program there's going to
be incredible variants in it and this
takes place at regular colleges and
universities and it took place at our
prison campus too
there are some guys who are going to
swallow everything that they can find
try to digest it try to make it their
own
they're naturally curious
there's some guys that are like that
that are basically all about trying to
have have uh power and trying to make
themselves into the the smart guy that
everybody has to listen to
there's some people who are um humble
and and you know
sort of unassuming and they turn out to
be some of the best students because
they they take they're very methodical
they take each little piece and put it
together and build and build and build
there's some guys who got into the
education thing just so they could get
out of their cells and we're not going
to apply themselves they're going to you
know sneak off to the bathroom you know
and hang out and joke around and stuff
like that
you have this incredibly wide range and
people change over time
somebody goes from being some some class
clown jackass you know that they were in
the first semester to being kind of
subdued and thoughtful by the third
semester and then by the fifth semester
they've actually like blossomed and
become a leader in discussion and are
helping other guys
with understanding the material i've
seen that happen
so what i want to talk about
with with respect to this having a lot
of different variants
i i think that's a good thing
and that's part of the goods of
education
um
and i want to talk about how this plays
out in in in terms of groups or
communities
both um
in a kind of
base
almost static sense and then also in a
in a time progressive
diachronic you know moving through time
at the same
pace kind of sense what we would call
having an educational cohort
so let's start with cohorts
first every semester that i was at at uh
indiana state prison we would have a new
crop of of prison students come in
and
these were guys for the most part who
had earned their their geds in the
prison
and
they were going to start taking these
base classes these core classes they
would have a lot of classes together
they were exposed to professors for the
first time
and
some of them had discipline problems a
lot of them a lot of them didn't quite
frankly at least not in my classes
and
they would learn by watching each other
and a lot of learning is actually
screwing up and giving the wrong answer
and then like
you know being shown why it's the wrong
answer not just getting smacked down
it's a stupid wrong answer but actually
well why is that the wrong answer i mean
let's look at what the book actually
says why does the book say this over
here and why did you end up over here
let's let's figure out where the
interference area is
and
being in the same classroom with other
guys
with whom that was happening
was a for the most part positive
experience for these guys they learned a
lot by
by engaging with each other by by
studying the material together by
talking about it these guys would
actually leave the classroom and they
would go black they would go back to
their cells and they would study and
they would talk about the material with
each other and they would raise
questions and they would argue with each
other
sort of thing we want students to be
doing
you know
that's what it meant to go through a
cohort and they would see each other
mature over time so there were guys that
would be you know five semesters in and
there'd be another guy who's five
semesters in and he's acting kind of
like a like a jackass and they would say
to him hey quit playing the fool
you know you got
three semesters left after this one you
better buckle down and knock it out and
make sure that you actually get
everything out of this you can
and they would listen to each other you
know that that was important
and i think what's going on there is a
shared good
you know there's a good of education
which is that of
of truth that of acquiring
the knowledge
uh not just information but but what in
educational theory if you're an
aristotelian or atomist you would call a
hexis a habitus
something that is developed within you
think of it as like a framework that
that's within your your mind or your
soul something that's lasting that
allows you to to wrap your mind around
things with greater strength and greater
flexibility and greater adaptability and
penetration into the subject
there's that's a good
that's also a good that's shared in an
educational cohort
with other other guys
also shared with me i mean i learned a
lot from from these guys
i learned how to be a good teacher
actually by by teaching these poor guys
because i wasn't a good teacher when i
started
the other thing is
there was an even
wider set of overlapping educational
communities within the prison within
indiana state prison because there were
guys who had done their college with
ball state 15 years before and 10 years
before and five years before
and some of them you know they they
finish their college and then they say
i'm not going to bother with this
anymore but a lot of them the bug had
caught them
and they were still reading plato
where they were still reading history
and discussing it and saying yeah the
history channel actually got this crap
wrong because the history channel hires
you know a bunch of hacks that that you
know are just trying to go for ratings
here's what actually took place and they
would communicate this with other guys
and they would discuss this and they
would argue about it and some of them
would continue to carry out research
that set up ideals
for the younger men
to be able to see
and they could say you know
this education stuff isn't just about
you know getting out of my cell
or getting a job later on
man those guys life is better than mine
there's something that they've got
and i don't know exactly how it came
about but going to ball state at indiana
state prison made that happen i better
go do that
there's a communication of good
through through communities of education
that takes place if they're genuine
communities
and these communities included not just
the guys who'd gone through ball state
but also the guys who'd gone through
grace college which was another college
there
and it included the religious
communities
these these overlapped you know there
were there's a sunni muslim community
there was a catholic community there was
sort of a general protestant community
there was a small eastern orthodox
community um there was a native american
religion community that actually ended
up you know getting close to i'm not
sure if they actually did get a sweat
lodge up there but they were able to get
close to it
and as i got to know these guys and as i
got to know their community leaders and
as i got to interact with them i found
these communities in large part
supporting my work as an educator up
there
at indiana state prison
so there were lots of different shared
goods that that took place
now what about arguments against prison
education i mean i've talked all about
these you know these things that took
place but maybe somebody had come along
and said i don't care about that you
know i'm only interested in the money
that this costs
um or i'm only interested in the fact
that
these guys are are criminals they ought
to be punished things that shouldn't be
good for them
well you know like i said at the
beginning i actually i can understand
and i can even empathize with some of
these points and i've argued with many
many people about this including many of
my family members
and i had to think about this by myself
how i i view these things
so let's take the one about unfairness
first
i think this was part of what was lying
behind
the the sentiment that led to
ending prison education in indiana
post-secondary education
the basic idea and i see this brought up
every time that i talk about prison
education is that
look these guys violated the social
contract they violated the law they're
in prison we're already paying for these
guys to be there
that's costing us taxpayers money
why should we be making anything nice
for them why should we be providing
them with with education i mean we're
providing them three square meals which
actually doesn't turn out to be true but
that's a whole different issue
and you know a safe environment also not
entirely true
and shelter clothing
why are we going
above and beyond to provide these guys
with with something that not everybody
else on the outside has
a college education
well there's a lot of things to be said
to this
first off
when it comes to indiana
the state money that was going to to
fund these guys
they were getting they were getting the
same grant
that
all the low-income people who want to go
to college
in indiana get
and a large proportion of indiana
college students are getting these
grants
so it's not like they were robbing
anybody of their opportunity you know
the legislature a long time before that
created these these grants
as a way to try to equalize educational
opportunity
nobody else on the outside was being
prevented from getting these grants
so that argument doesn't really stand up
um
you know say well there's limited pie
and you know they're you're taking too
much for these guys here
um
it used to be that they could get pell
grants but that ended a long time ago
and they had to go through the same
financial aid bs as all the other
college students filling out a fafsa you
know which is an irritating kind of
thing
another thing to keep in mind too when
it came to
to
indiana in particular
i would have relatives and i would have
colleagues and i would have friends when
i would travel out of state to illinois
to wisconsin to other places
who would get upset about indiana having
this program in place and being willing
to educate prisoners allow them to get a
four-year degree and these were usually
people who were in states
that didn't have prison education
and my response to them
was usually
what do you care with the state of
indiana chooses to do with its money
you're not paying for it it's not a
federal program that's coming out of
your income taxes and it's not coming
out of your illinois income taxes that
are being spent pretty poorly on your
own educational system
this is indiana citizens who are footing
the bill
for you know low-income students who
happen to be in in prison
what do you care what business is it of
yours so then we we get to issues of
fairness
and there it's it's not so much about
the dollars per se or who's paying for
it
it's a mere fact that
look you know
these guys have violated basic social
norms they're supposed to be being
punished that's the purpose of prisons
isn't it
and
um
you know the response to that is well no
prisons actually serve a bunch of
different purposes
if you look at
you know criminology and theories of
punishment
there's more than one reason why you
could punish it might be
what you call incapacitation just
keeping these guys out of circulation
until they can be you know relied upon
not to not to act badly because you know
a lot of violent crime traditionally in
societies takes place among young men
of certain ages
and there may be some people who just
want to take out a circulation right
could be deterrence
could be that by by making an example
out of certain people you you keep other
people out there from committing crimes
could be rehabilitation that's that's
one reason that
people want to put other people in
prison because you know one alternative
to this is just we kill everybody right
we can have capital crimes or we could
we could allow
mobs to to punish people as they see fit
we don't have to put people in prison
when we do put people in prison
you know there's usually a number of
different things going on it's not just
about punishing them it's not just about
what you call the
retributive
or retributional theory of punishment
um
but even that you know i'm and i'm
sympathetic to to the notion of
punishment as being retribution
i don't actually have a problem with
that
there's a few things that you have to
like keep in mind with that
one is
that
there's nothing to keep you from
carrying out retribution
and incapacitation
or rehabilitation all at the same time i
mean you can do that you can punish
somebody for their crime
and also allow them to complete an
education how are you punishing them for
for their crime well look they don't get
to go outside these walls and their
entire life is spent
within all these different structures
where somebody is telling them what to
do or watching them all the time
and they're they're living quarters
they're you know quite frankly suck uh
you know they're
they're they're not getting a lot of
creature comforts if you've ever like
looked inside a maximum security prison
they are not kush places
um there's all sorts of you know things
that these guys have to put up with on a
regular basis
prisons are pretty punitive at least in
indiana i don't know i don't know what
they're liking
in
certain states i mean i've only taught
in prisons in indiana and north carolina
and i can tell you both of them are
pretty punitive
uh they're not they're not nice places
that you'd want to hang out you know
minimum security you know what they call
club fed or stuff like that for the
white collar criminals yeah that's a
whole different thing but i'm not
talking about that i'm talking about the
places that murderers kidnappers you
know
uh rapists
high-class drug offenses those kind of
places
people go to
so even if you hold a retributional
theory of punishment that doesn't keep
you from saying that that you could have
prison education
you're you know you're really going to
take education
and the opportunity to engage in that a
way is like one more way to stick it to
these guys to make sure that they know
that
that they're being um
punished
you know punishment itself if you look
at philosophical theories of punishment
punishment itself is supposed to be in
certain respects educational it goes
that goes all the way back to plato
so
the notion that you would like you know
punish these guys further by taking away
one of the few good things one of the
things that allows them to you know look
at themselves and really think about who
they are and make choices to become
better people
you're gonna take that away from them
that's the kind of punishment that
actually makes people worse
that's that's stupid
um and you know if you think about it
that that's that's kind of irrational
so
what else
can we say about this um
you know
the prison environment itself
because it it's so spartan and already
kind of dangerous
and uncomfortable
um
it lends itself very well to to
carrying out education i think
a lot of these guys had a lot fewer
distractions and were able to get more
out of education
so
you almost get more bang for your buck
than you would by paying for a bunch of
18 year old kids
to come in and sit in a classroom and
then go out and do whatever they're
going to do the rest of the time
let me consider another argument that
people make about prison education they
say look you're just wasting money on
these guys these guys are
not worth the resources that we're
spending on them
it already costs a lot to keep these
guys locked up
well
if you want to reduce everything down to
money like that
it costs an awful lot to keep these guys
locked up it does not cost an awful lot
to also educate them at the same time as
a matter of fact
that was pretty cheap to do
and it was a great investment because it
cut recidivism so much if you want the
best way of actually keeping people out
of prison a good established
well-structured prison education program
you get the most bang for your buck that
way
i understand that means that you got to
like put up with
people getting an education in prison
and feeling like hey why are they
getting to go for free well i gotta pay
for my kids over here well because they
don't earn anything
they're the same low income as as all
the other people over there in your
kid's school who are also getting by
because they have you know not that much
money and you actually have enough money
to send your kid to school and i i'm hip
to this because i'm gonna have to pay
pay to send my kids to school myself
um but you know just think about the
argument itself
if you're if you want to get the most
bang for your buck if you want to get
the best return on investment
then spending the amount of money to
actually have a prison education program
that's that's a great way to do it
that makes sense
and if you want to know
whether there actually is a return on
investment for this sort of thing
you you need to talk to somebody who's
actually worked in the prisons
who's actually paid attention to it you
need to talk to some of the people who
were educated in prison or who carried
out the process of education in prison
and asked them about what their
experiences were and you know what their
insights that developed over time were
rather than just you know talking to
some bureaucrat or some legislature who
probably doesn't know anything about the
topic let alone a talk host a
tv talk show host or somebody like that
the last thing that i'm going to
consider is you know some people say
you know why are we why are we sending
these guys to college
when really they should we should be
putting our focus on ged programs or
vocational tech programs or business
management
you know like like they did for a while
and
there's two answers to that one is we
already do that
every prison system already has ged
education
that's it's not a question of whether we
should
either send them to college or give them
geds they they actually go to college
most these guys after they get a ged
so that's kind of a fake issue
what about you know vocational training
you know shouldn't they be spending
their time on learning you know skills
like landscaping or culinary arts or
hvac or you know things electric you
know electrical things
there's nothing to keep them from doing
that either because those programs
already exist too as a matter of fact
indiana is thinking somehow they're
going to expand those
and that's all they're going to have
they're going to replace all the college
education with vocational tech training
um
is there something and here's what i'm
going to close with
is there something that
is
afforded to these guys that develops in
them that you would want to see happen
in them if they were a regular college
student somewhere else
and you definitely want to see in guys
who committed major crimes and are being
re-released into our in you know
environment and community
is there something
that a liberal arts education with a
four-year degree affords them
that a ged
or vocational training
or a business degree or it degree
isn't going to give them
not in every you know 100 of the cases
but in a lot of the cases is there
something there i think there is i saw
it actually happen
i talked about this earlier in the video
but that's something for you to think
about whenever people start talking
about this ah we shouldn't you know send
these guys to college in prison
if there really is something there that
that affords them the opportunity to
change who they are
then it's a good thing that we do that
it's not just a good thing for them i'm
willing to do it just because it's good
for them it's a good thing for us those
of us who are
you know having all these people
released from prison back into society
and don't want to see them go back into
prison so we don't have to pay for them
and we don't want to see them commit new
crimes out here we want to see them
become reintegrated within society
i think getting a ba in
a humanities based curriculum is
probably the best way to do that
so that's where i'll leave off